so you're working from home you're
feeling anxious you're isolated you've
eaten all of your quarantine snacks and
your dog doesn't know any new jokes well
you're not alone for science contributor
Valerie stomach is here to chat with the
ultimate expert is social isolation
former NASA astronaut and International
Space Station commander Leroy Chiao he
spent over 229 days in very close
quarters miles away from the nearest
beach bar or store and he's here to
offer you some tips and tricks on
surviving social isolation as we flatten
the curve I've experienced in this kind
of partial isolation especially social
isolation part of being aboard a space
station for six and a half months and so
I've kind of thought about some of the
perspectives and parallels between
long-duration spaceflight and what much
of the world is now experiencing with
this coronavirus pandemic tell us a
little bit about the time you've spent
how much time you spent in space what
some of your activities were so over my
15 year NASA career I was in space for
just a little over 229 days over my four
missions of course the longest flight
was 193 days that was the Space Shuttle
a Space Station mission the Space
Shuttle missions were typically seven to
14 days in duration so much sure I'd
love if you could share some tips with
us that you have from your own
experience about how you deal with any
of the isolation that you experienced
maybe if you have a personal story about
holy right so from my long-duration
flights I've given this some thought you
know what we're experiencing here on
earth during this pandemic with people
you know kind of isolated in their homes
and number one I think is that you see
the bigger picture you keep in your
perspective and set realistic
expectations I know it's difficult with
the uncertainty we don't know how long
we're gonna have to be kind of partially
isolated things like that you know what
resources do you have and how long you
might be in this situation and like I
said there's a lot of uncertainty about
that but that helps you prepare mentally
number two is operations make sure that
your surroundings everything is working
as much as possible
within reason in our example of space
flight of course we are concerned about
our vehicle in my case the international
space station making sure things were
tidy and organized making sure things
were fixed and operational so in your
own home make sure that as much as
possible things are in a state of good
repair and you're making your
surroundings as comfortable as possible
number three is take stock of your
supplies fortunately stores are open you
can go buy things please try to avoid
the urge to go and panic buy because
you're gonna create health create
artificial shortages that hurt everyone
and my case aboard the International
Space Station during the first few
months of our mission we experienced a
food shortage and so we had to ration
food for about 4 weeks we each lost fry
around 5 or maybe a few more pounds than
that and we had to you know but we had
our expectations set because we knew
that the resupply ship was going to be
bringing up more supplies and points
identity it did arrive on Christmas Day
keep your channels of communication open
a hoard space zones we still had email
we could send email back and forth VoIP
phone was really a nice thing to be able
to actually call your family and your
friends and have short conversations
while the antenna was was pointing at
the satellite you also you want to keep
your spirits up number five is you know
do things to help each other
I mentioned the food shortage we can't
afford ISS and during that time my
Russian crew mate and I we would joke
with each other and joke about how close
we were and try to make each other laugh
to make light of it we dealt with it
with humor so that's what we need to do
in this time to you know you help each
other you try to keep each other's
spirits up whether it's your business
space mission or your neighbors you know
let's let's all help each other you know
share supplies if someone's little
things like that and we'll get through
this you know we always do
[Music]
you